this week convict zone is in Berlin and
so is my guest the iraqi prime minister
haider al-abadi you wouldn't want his
job really running a country that's
drowning in violence and corruption and
occupied in large swathe by so-called
Islamic state so does the Iraqi
government actually control anything at
all
I got a la body welcome to conflict zone
okay thank you when you were in Davos at
the World Economic Forum you gave a very
bleak assessment of your position you
said it's impossible to run the country
to be honest with you to sustain the
military to sustain jobs to sustain the
economy sounded like a prime minister
giving up are you giving up no I just
tried to explain the challenges so the
world can stand with us pretty bleak
challenges well they were I mean when
when our income from all drops to 15% -
what were they were two years ago and we
have war at our hand that was not with
the local terror organization but with
the international terrorist organization
and we have liberated I mean that
organization was controlling 40% of the
Iraqi land when I took over now they're
only controlling 16 percent of that land
it means we have liberated many of these
areas I think we have succeeded this
challenge alright well we'll come to
that in a minute but in the short time
since 2014 that you've been in power
you've made many promises haven't you
and some of them haven't come true have
they when you came to values promise to
heal the Sunni Shiite rift according to
the Brookings Institution there's an
absence of any meaningful reconciliation
between Sunni and Shia now in the
country Wow I think you didn't deliver
on that I don't know where they're
living probably another planet I think
now if you look two years ago our
military were not welcome in the
scenarios and remodeled areas but very
much welcomed and the local people are
fighting alongside our military to take
the city back and we took it back
they're very much welcome so I think
that harmony between communities is back
in Tikrit Sunni and Shia are blowing
each other up in car bombs and suicide
bombs well that's that's Amy aren't they
almost daily in your country not not
true that's not a reconciliation is it
if you look at terrorist attacks in
Baghdad they had dropped drastically
that's why a single terse attack you
hear in the news now before it used to
be two three a day you're building more
checkpoints no is less checkpoint is the
opposite I don't know whether you get
that first problem in from the Interior
Minister no material
well I said they're building more
checkpoints is that hot off the routes
that Isis uses to take their car bombs
in the city now it's not a measure of
success when you build more checkpoints
no is the opposite we have reduced
checkpoints and the city's people are
not in fact that it's been in Baghdad if
you go and back that long distance
everybody in Baghdad now even you you
talk to two foreign ambassadors in
Baghdad they said we haven't seen the
city as fearful as it is at the moment
I've removed a night careful which has
been in place since 2003 I've ruined a
hundreds of checkpoints in the city as
many less checkpoints the city is much
peaceful than before well then your
interior ministry is saying something
else idea who's in charge of spokes
being a spokesman for the ministry said
that they were building new checkpoints
no we are no that's different now where
are you you objected to the the term
building of war and they said we are
building new checkpoints exactly around
Baghdad not inside well that's not
exactly a sign of confidence no it is a
sign of witness developers it we're
trying to make the country more peaceful
I'm trying to make the movement of the
public much easier now we have
difficulties and moving citizens going
into Baghdad because back that is the
capital is the home of 23% of the
population of Iraq terrorists are trying
to return back to their bombing campaign
as they used to be before we're trying
to prevent that and to make the movement
of the people much much more peaceful
it's the opposite exactly no sir you've
also promised that you would eliminate
corruption 2016 is the year of
eliminating corruption you know it's not
a tap that you can simply turn off
corruption is endemic in your country
isn't it it's another promise that you
can't deliver on islets well I agree but
this is but it's a promise that we will
put the procedure to eliminate air
corruptions corruption take a long time
to talk to Arad
2016 is the year of eliminating
corruption you said in speech January
the 9th
there is no such thing as acceptable
corruption you're not going to eliminate
it in 2016 well that's that's for the
Ministry of Interior that was speech for
the
the establishment or for the Minister of
Interior but if you make promises that
you can't deliver on how can people
check out you [ __ ] evangelist for
2016 I made a promise for the minister
of Tyria that was four that will
eliminate corruption in the ministry
it's all right just in the ministry that
was for particular that ministries that
wasn't in the translation well it will
be the year of eliminating hurry up or
the Ministry of Interior it was the
speech was for that and I think we have
started this process I want to eliminate
it corruption is a disease and sometimes
it's instituted and institutionalized I
want to remove this when you remove it
you're almost killed corruption but that
is saying there detector is to remove it
but at least I'll make bureaucracy I'll
remove bureaucracy right tip make it
easier for the citizens for the
companies for the private sector to work
in the country but that's your aim you
can't promise it that's you know we're
moving along that line and once I do
that it means I've killed corruption
from source perhaps the biggest promise
you've made promise is that Iraq will be
free of Islamic state in 2016 2016 you
say will be the year of the big and
final victory when Dash's Islamic States
presence in Iraq will be terminated if
you can't deliver that this year in 2016
will you resign well I don't might
resign at any moment but not trying to
get the country not thinking about my
responsibilities this is a solemn
promise isn't it well it's this year -
clear - out of Iraq in 2016 this is your
promise my promise is this we're
starting a campaign to liberate nainawa
Muslim so you're redefining your problem
well I said it exactly like that I was
talking about muscle and in motion this
is the last campaign this is the last
place where - is controlling and in this
year with Fallujah Fallujah and the
seizures were what Fallujah was under
siege two years ago before - rolled into
the country so that's completely
different story I'm addressing this but
no but - still controls I know of
thousands of square kilometers of your
turn well it's only 16 percent was 40
percent now 16 percent of that land is
controlled by - that's a huge success
it is you
you said yourself they're still a very
dangerous threat in Iraq
well of course so I come back to how can
you get rid of them very easily in 2016
as you want us to do
terrorism is not my problem it is on me
but that's international community
problem that was created outside Iraq
and was enabled to cross the border into
Iraq and occupied large chunks of Iraq
and destroy cities and make millions of
people refugees into their own country
were trying to reverse that but that
terrorism is an international problem
there are bombings in Paris there
problems bombings in Europe just talking
about what's happening in Iraq and you
you've taken back to Crete you took back
sinja baiji and now Ramadi but when it
comes to Ramadi you shouldn't have lost
Ramadi in the first place
Isis was outnumbered by your forces and
yet they still lost the city and
according to the US Defense Secretary
was speaking last May the problem was
that the will of the Iraqis to fight
ISIL and defend themselves wasn't there
what can you tell me to show people that
that will to fight is there will predict
on the ground our forces have liberated
not only Ramadi or they're a huge
American help all areas surrounding
American how well I'm not denying this
from the air not on the ground the only
people who are fighting on the grounds
are Iraqis by with their own blood we
haven't lost a single foreign force in
Iraq because they are from the air
supporting our forces and now 60% almost
of air combat are carried out by Iraqis
we didn't have that a year and a half
ago now we build our capabilities much
better than before and we're relying on
us say you've built the capabilities
moving before in 2015 the Pentagon said
it's a plan to Train 24,000 Iraqi
soldiers but only 7,000 turned up in
only 2000 for a counterterrorism service
so it doesn't sound like much of a will
to fight with so few people turning up
to fight does it well I think I think
that's a claim which have food is not
credible on the ground we liberated not
only Ramadi best blood chunk of that
area before when I inherited that place
our forces were inside
we're all there is outside Ramadi was
controlled by - not anymore so you
saying the the Pentagon doesn't know
what he's talking about
well I think that they have their
opinion I don't know when that was said
all right last October just four months
ago general macbeth Nurik former senior
u.s. officer in iraq estimated that you
have only five functioning divisions
roughly fifty thousand men with fighting
readiness of between 60 and 65 percent
that's not very much is it no I think is
we have more than that but I've out of
14 divisions so it's only up to 60 or
65% no I think we have more than that at
the moment you think we've increased the
numbers don't forget our many of our
forces collapse when - rolls into here
we have to rebuild that I don't have
like some rapid fix for this we have to
build it we are moving in the right
direction we have liberated large areas
of our country - on is on the retreat at
the moment militarily but if you talk
about security threat it's not only back
that our Iraq is threatened Clinton is
threatened all the world is threatened
by - but you have in Fallujah at the
moment a humanitarian disaster don't you
you have people dying because they don't
have enough food well there are people
in all conscience could you let that
happen there are people dying in Syria
and then in their thousands there are
people dying in Mosul because - somebody
has enabled - to come into Iraq and
control Muslim and there are people
dying in Fallujah because some countries
have enabled - to come there and conquer
the city and control it some cases which
countries I mean well you know I mean
some countries which country well - is
not spontaneous it's not like terrorist
organization was created for nothing but
you've made an accusation which country
I'm talking about facts well okay so
give me the phone well I mean you well I
think is not it's not I mean probably
the I mean some of your foreign
ministers some of your politicians will
tell you that which countries are
supporting I think and you won't tell me
know the problem you're gonna make an
accusation but you're not going to back
it up on the front I'm talking about
fact here okay so no - is the terrorist
organization who has been armed
whipped and was trained in Syria and
crossed into Iraq all of a sudden and
occupied many cities in Iraq if that has
happened spontaneously without any
support I don't think the world the
world is right
so yes I'm alone in the world so what
are you gonna do about this humanitarian
disaster well I'm dying of star we have
helping we are helping we're trying to
end the siege of fur there's not a siege
at the moment we don't have a siege you
know a Terran aid is not getting it well
no we are getting material aid the
government has one says the situation is
terrible I'm saying this is terrible not
now it's terrible for the last two years
people been executed being killed they
have been starved in the city and and
most on another areas they've been
killed by the day by - we're trying to
liberate the people meanwhile - is using
the people as a human shield they trying
to kill them they trying to cause hunger
to them we have open set corridors for
the population and for the civilian
civilians and we are welcoming them to
leave the city
to other safe areas what chances have
you got of taking Mosul this year
Kurdistan's deputy prime minister kuba
talabani said last month I don't think
the most on offensive could happen this
year I don't think the Iraqi armed
forces are ready and I don't think the
us-led coalition is confident in the
ability of everyone to get ready in time
for an offensive this year so no
offensive on Mosul this year no we
started I mean we're ready we started
deploying forces in East Muslim last
week and they are ongoing our process is
ongoing we're on plan now to start this
is not like Ramadi this is a completely
different battle you're gonna have to
fight here well I know it's unlike
Ramadi I know as I like baiji where -
has recruited and pushed for their best
terrorist fighters to take it back they
couldn't we liberated it with ability to
create we liberated Ramadi and I hope
and we are planning to be successful in
retaking Mosul back one of David
Petraeus former intelligence advisors
Michael preached and said last month the
force to retake Mosul hasn't been built
yet we can't take it back with Peshmerga
and Christian forces and we certainly
can't take it back with sheer militias
but we'll take it back with Iraqi
security forces and with people inside
the city even with much fewer numbers
and by your own admission an army that
you can no longer fund because you don't
have the more that's another problem yes
we don't have the funding in a funding
but we have the funding to take Mosul
but well we haven't had the funding for
2015
our oil income has dropped for to the
whole of 2015 to 30% or 2/3 of what it
was but we liberated Tikrit we liberated
our Ramadi with a little bit a lot of
archers never have lost well yeah we
should have never a lot but we were in a
very critical position where a lot of
the city and the surrounding area was
under the control of - and our army was
didn't have the capability to fight back
- because they didn't have the will no
they didn't have the weapons against
truck bombs
let's talk if we made by the Shiite
militias who've gained enormous Lee in
power and influence under your
leadership their leader Hadi allomere he
seems to think he can push you around
when he feels like it last September he
said in a television interview that if
the Shiite groups didn't like US
military actions in Iraq we can go to
Abadi he said and the government and
pressure them either you will do this or
we will do that is that the relationship
you have with Shia militias they push
you around
well militias are not allowed to buy
your active Constitution
okay so you've taken them in under your
wing now you pay for them but they are
Shiite militias well now we have all
Iraqi citizens fighting alongside the
Iraqi security forces under the public
mobilization force which is legal force
under the Iraqi budget which has been
approved by Parliament they're fighting
alongside our security forces to
liberate their own areas they may be
fighting alongside but their widespread
human rights abuses reported both by the
UN and human rights groups have been
pushing Sunnis into the arms of -
haven't they well they have been before
that's why - was there in the first
place but there are much more I mean
streaming communities are siding with us
if you're looking in for for Ramadi
civilians are moving we're moving in
their thousands towards our security
forces and it's a very leaving -
you'll say that's about the two or two
weeks ago these militia groups were
accused by Human Rights Watch of
possible war crimes in the abduction and
killing of scores of sunni civilians in
the east of your country and in the
unlawful destruction of their property
I'm talking about
mcdhh idea the cafe bombing that took
place there in retaliation your militias
attacked Sunnis as well as their homes
and mosques and killed at least a dozen
people we don't have militias look there
are eyewitness reports yet we don't have
I don't have militias in the state there
are outlaws that people who are taken
the law into their own hands we have -
who's taken the law into their own hands
that criminals were fighting them and
there are other criminal gangs who
taking the law into their own hands 101
eyewitness said Isis may have been
behind the cafe bombing that the attacks
on sunni houses mosques and people in
our area was the league of the righteous
and the League of the righteous is a
Shiite militia group isn't it well
that's a statement if I have a proof for
that I will act I went myself three days
after the bombing I'm sure by myself it
was so spontaneous it was a criminal act
but the one who had this warming of the
cafe and killed many people the number
that has been killed by the bombing of
the major bombing only six people has
been filled up in that latter month
once again Human Rights Watch says
civilians are paying the price for
Iraq's failure to rein in out-of-control
militias and this has been a widespread
pattern in the region hasn't it
Human Rights Watch says both Isis and
Iraq s-- government affiliated militias
are committing atrocities against
civilians with evidence support from
their commanders the UN High
Commissioner for Human Rights says he's
had these reports as well very
disturbing reports I had this friend you
and you claimed that no these these
crimes aren't taking place I'm not
saying that I said we're not proud of
them we compared them and we try to
remove them but I need evidence
every time I challenge for evidence I
want to catch these people I don't want
to punish a whole communities I cannot
do that I cannot punish the Sunnis
because of - I cannot punish the Shia
because of some militias are outlaws I
have to find the culprits catch their
and punish them by law if people don't
produce evidence for me I cannot do it
now - is committed you know it's going
on of course people are afraid to come
forward and testify because there's so
much hatred between the groups the
groups that you said were reconciling
but not exactly on the evidence of the
atrocities that we're seeing one carried
out by Shia militias in Sunni areas
destruction of property abduction of
people I mean the extrajudicial killing
well that's exact alive which have been
reported rights groups which and you
know this is going on but not to the
extent you're talking about I don't know
what you're talking about I don't know
what your your information - you've
taken expert excel's from certain things
out of their context you're taking
registers by me out of their context
this is not acceptable I don't accept
this I thought this is very hostile Iraq
is fighting a war against terrorism we
tried our best to fight them we're
trying to the best to fight the outlaws
in our country is not is no black and
white I cannot just send the country
upside down in one day there are a lot
of problems in this country a lot of
countries intervening in my country
there has been a lot of support to
terrorism to militias in my country
we're trying to fix it I cannot carry
responsibility talk for everything wrong
we trying to rectify it
I'm not responsible for criminals I'll
catch them when I have evidence I cannot
catch people like this
I cannot execute people the streets I
mean I need justice in the country and I
need evidence we're doing our best to do
it yes there are criminal activities
there are people working against us
there are people trying to weaken the
country but we are performing Iraq look
one and a half year ago the country was
at the brink of division I bring what
the whole total collapse we're in a much
better position now than that time the
Washington representatives for these
militia groups or popular mobilization
forces a man called Bassam reader told
the u.s. news outlet this month that he
knew such abuses were happening but said
they couldn't stop them more
disturbingly he revealed that no one has
been jailed for any of these atrocities
he said they go inside prison inside the
military camps and usually they are let
go
they've done a lot of vicious activities
a lot of bad crimes but they get away
with it
why did they get a well I talked to him
I might watch I want them I told him I
wanted evidence I want to catch these
people if you have evidence
well they said we get some information
by telephone and we ask people and we
cannot give evidence for that and most
of the stories that are giving I
investigated and give them the answers
for that as far as my investigation are
going through I want as a prime minister
to catch criminals wherever they are
whatever had they are well even if they
are among the electricity forces they
only belong to themselves in their kind
they don't belong to their activity
forces and we have to stop them and we
have been doing this for some time but
German White's watch is not making up
these stories the UN Human Rights
Commission's that make the ROIs to the
roller of the human rights agencies is
to expose human rights abuses and
they're not going to say when the dices
of the testam anything of course they
have this well I mean that's their job
I'm happy they don't make it out well we
have our own human rights organization
inside Iraq they are interpreted from
the government they've been voted in by
Parliament and they're doing their
trumpets as they give me
they give me evidence they give me a
report I act among accomplice and
according the information you have but
if these abuses don't stop it's a return
to the days of dictatorship isn't it
well I know yes but not by the state we
are fighting them there are two
different things but they're out of
control well they are that is this is
that not just that I say licious as well
is that reaction when - comes in there's
reaction to a - and everything is under
control we'll bring it to bring you all
under control
we have to catch these criminals we have
to punish them and we are doing it yes
maybe not enough done because it's very
hard situation is a war and in the war
you cannot catch people easily
you cannot investigate many things in
the wall it takes time to investigate
things do you have the power to enact
real change in Iraq fighting a war on so
many different fronts fighting with
corruption fighting with political
opposition fighting with - Islamic state
in your country do you really
have the power to enact real change all
depends all political bloc's I think we
we have a system that Prime Minister is
owned in his own we have the judiciary
you have Parliament and you have other
forces that element starts to block your
your reform I mean well that is well
that's politics as everywhere you have a
problem between Parliament and the
promises got to take Parliament with him
you're not taking Parliament with you
you know it's they blocked your reform
no no they they couldn't block all of it
I mean they blocked part of it it's not
easy
I had reforms that reforms has touched
on sensitive issues which sample Philip
locks didn't like so they tried to block
it but they couldn't block all of them
remember the parliamentary Finance
Committee said we withdrew the power
that we gave to mr. Abady because his
behavior was unconstitutional and body
is neglecting Parliament he said well
that's a view of course this is my suit
haider well I don't know the guy but
still but still I think I mean he's
right to have his statement that we have
200 328 Parliament areas not all of them
are happy with the government they want
to have their say against the government
I worked on that and I listened to it is
your country uncover noble notice
governor no no money everyone trying to
grab what they can well as many many
countries they went through this through
the collapse of economy our coal economy
didn't collapse yet its collapse of
economy collapse of security well it's
all ranged but there's no collapse yes
we have a problem this is not our own
making when the oil prices weight goes
down this is a problem outside Iraq but
we have to manage our economy we have to
manage our country we trying our best
and we'll win you're coming up to a
crucial reshuffle of your cabinet you
promised that you would end the system
whereby political bloc's get an abortion
of the appointments there may be a vote
of no confidence in you well it's ok if
Parliament decide that you prepared to
go oh that's a democracy if they decide
I prepared to go your position is that
fragile at the moment Walters in fragile
no I disagree I called for amendment to
the government for government reshuffle
at this time I think to do it now postal
blocks
I call upon them to cooperate with me to
do that
I I know some positions will still
people the compositions because the
supporting government my position is
political myself as a Prime Minister of
the country and then the son some would
people to cover pointees I'm happy with
that as long as they can't carry on the
job not just appointees with that
abilities they must have the ability to
their job alright prime minister haider
al-abadi thanks very much for being on
complex on thank you
you